Cuando os hablan de terrorismo yihadista, ¿qué
es lo primero que se os viene a la cabeza?
Seguramente el ataque al World Trade Center
en nueva York en 2001, el atentado en la sala
bataclán en París, el ISIS luchando salvajemente
en siria o Irak, o el atentado del 11 m en España.
Es decir, que, por lo general, situamos al
yihadismo en Oriente Medio, África y Europa.
Pero ¿y si os dijera que ya va siendo hora
de poner a Sudamérica en ese mapa? ¿Y si os
dijera que hay un país latinoamericano donde
el yihadismo ya tiene una fuerte presencia?
Fijaos:
N1 (Yihadistas del Caribe:
por qué Trinidad y Tobago se ha convertido en
capital del Dáesh en Occidente. “Jesucristo
está personificado como un hombre blanco de ojos
azules y la gente odia la supremacía blanca”,
dice un imán bajo anonimato. El Español)
Efectivamente, ni Argentina, ni Colombia,
ni México… el país que muchos analistas
califican como el mayor nido de yihadistas
en todo occidente es Trinidad y Tobago.
Trinidad y Tobago es una nación formada
por dos islas principales
frente a la costa de Venezuela.
Este pequeño país, que antes destacaba sobre
todo por ser un gran exportador de petróleo
y gas natural, está hoy en el punto de mira de
la inteligencia antiterrorista internacional.
El yihadismo y la violencia se han apoderado de su
territorio, y tanto es así que Trinidad y Tobago
tiene la segunda mayor tasa de homicidios
del continente americano. Una barbaridad
Así que amigos, las preguntas están
claras, ¿cómo diantres se convirtió
Trinidad y Tobago en el epicentro occidental
del yihadismo? ¿Qué implicaciones tendrá de
cara a la seguridad global? ¿Se avecina
una nueva oleada terrorista en occidente?
Hoy, en VisualPolitik, os
lo contamos todo. ¡Atentos!
T1(EL GÉNESIS YIHADISTA)
Como muchos ya os imaginaréis, Trinidad y Tobago
no fue una excepción para los imperios coloniales
europeos: también estuvo bajo su control.
Desde 1592 con los primeros asentamientos
españoles, ambas islas pasaron por manos
francesas y terminaron finalmente bajo el
control británico, Se llegó a convertir en una
importante colonia productora de algodón y azúcar.
Y así fue hasta casi 400 años después, cuando en
1962, Trinidad y Tobago consiguió su independencia
de Reino Unido y, como seguro que muchos ya
estaréis pensando, no tardaron en aparecer
nuevos problemas para este recién nacido país.
Nada más conseguir su independencia, la economía
de Trinidad y Tobago comenzó a desplomarse por
la reducción en la demanda internacional de
sus principales productos de exportación,
como el cacao, el azúcar o los cítricos.
La tasa de desempleo alcanzó pronto el
15% para finales de los años 60 y las protestas
masivas en las calles se volvieron algo habitual.
No obstante, entre 1973 y 1981, debido al
embargo del petróleo saudita a occidente,
esta pequeña nación caribeña se benefició por
el aumento del precio del barril de petróleo:
¿el resultado? Un boom petrolero que le permitió
mejorar las condiciones de vida de sus ciudadanos.
Sin embargo, cuando las cosas con los árabes
volvieron a su cauce y terminó ese boom,
a principios de los 80, el nivel de gasto público
que había asumido el país de pronto se convirtió
en una losa insostenible. Y con la diferencia
entre las importaciones y las exportaciones,
pasó tres cuartas partes de lo mismo. En lugar de
ahorrar algo, Trinidad y Tobago se gastaba todo
el dinero que generaba con los hidrocarburos.
De esta forma, cuando los precios del crudo y
del gas cayeron… La economía del país entró en
recesión y, para 1989, la sociedad se encontraba
en una situación desesperante: un desempleo en
torno al 22% y el juvenil al 43%. Para colmo,
el gobierno tuvo que reducir los subsidios
que había creado durante la época de las vacas
gordas. Las protestas masivas estaban servidas
y el malestar social fue más evidente que nunca.
El país se encontraba casi al límite y, al
final, en 1990, pasó lo que suele pasar en
estas situaciones en los países jóvenes con
instituciones débiles: se produjo un golpe
de Estado. Pero ¡ojo!, no fue otro golpe de
Estado típico llevado a cabo por militares.
Nada de eso. Aquel golpe de Estado lo dio, nada
más y nada menos, que un grupo radical islamista:
el conocido como Jamaat al-Muslimeen.
Tal y como lo oís. En plena Sudamérica.
Este grupo, fundado en 1982 por este hombre
que veis en pantalla, Yasin Abu Bakr,
un antiguo agente de policía converso al islam,
intentó dar un golpe de Estado en julio de 1990.
Abu Bakr ya había tenido problemas con el gobierno
central cuando ocupó unas tierras que habían
sido concedidas a la Cofradía de Misioneros
Islámicos del Caribe y Sudamérica. De hecho,
en 1985 fue detenido por no acatar una sentencia
judicial que le ordenaba evacuar esas tierras,
y en 1988 el gobierno decidió llevar a cabo
una serie de redadas en ese lugar. Arrestaron
a 34 miembros de la organización por robo,
violación y asesinato, entre otros delitos.
Abu Bakr y sus fieles consideraron que
el gobierno les estaba oprimiendo y no
estaban por la labor de aceptarlo. Así,
aprovechando el tremendo malestar social
provocado por la crisis, el 27 de julio
de 1990, 112 rebeldes islamistas tomaron
tanto el parlamento como las oficinas
de la Televisión de Trinidad y Tobago.
El país se sumió en el caos y pronto
empezaron los saqueos. El resultado es
que 6 días y 24 muertos después, los rebeldes
desistieron y se entregaron con la promesa del
gobierno de concederles la amnistía.
Esta rebelión es, hasta día de hoy,
la única insurgencia religiosa islámica
que ha tenido occidente. Desde entonces,
los sucesivos gobiernos han ido adoptando reformas
austeras sin preocuparse demasiado del islamismo
radical. Sin embargo, estos últimos años han
dejado claro que eso fue un error. Atentos.
T2 (TIERRA FÉRTIL PARA EL EXTREMISMO)
Con el tiempo, los países van forjando una
reputación y una imagen propia para el resto
del mundo. Hay algunos que son conocidos por
exportar mucho petróleo, otros por ser potencias
financieras, y algunos por ser núcleos turísticos.
Sin embargo, en el caso de Trinidad
y Tobago, su reputación ha venido
forjándose por noticias como estas
N2 (3 de junio de 2007: Detienen a
tres acusados de planear un ataque contra
el aeropuerto JFK de Nueva York. El Mundo)
(15 de febrero de 2018: Detienen a cuatro personas
en Trinidad y Tobago por la amenaza terrorista
en carnavales. El Economista)
Trinidad y Tobago es el país
con mayor índice de yihadistas per cápita.
De hecho, siendo un país de apenas 1.300.000
habitantes, se calcula que hasta 240 de
sus ciudadanos se unieron al Daesh en
oriente medio. Una cifra que casi iguala a la
de EE. UU. multiplicando su población por 360.
La pregunta es ¿de dónde salen tantos
yihadistas en una nación tan pequeña?
Pues aquí las circunstancias
socioeconómicas juegan un papel importante.
La mayoría de los que se han unido al
daesh en Trinidad y Tobago cumplen con
tres características muy específicas:
son hombres afrodescendientes de unos
35 años que han sufrido discriminación,
provienen de un contexto de pobreza,
y a menudo, han estado en la cárcel.
En cualquier caso, el reclutamiento de
yihadistas y su expansión ha sido
especialmente fácil debido a la
existencia de una red nacional muy bien asentada.
Es decir, una red de reclutamiento extendida por
toda la isla de Trinidad.
En el centro de esta red
se encuentra el imán Nazim Mohammed.
Un hombre que ha negado constantemente
su relación con el dáesh, pero que, sin
embargo, tiene todos los datos en contra.
Por ejemplo, el 70% de los yihadistas
reclutados vivían cerca o dentro de
la comunidad religiosa que Mohamed preside.
Y, no solo eso, sino que unos 15 miembros de
su familia también se unieron al daesh en Siria
e Irak, incluida su propia hija y sus nietos.
Además, Mhammed está relacionado familiarmente con
emraan ali, un hombre que fue sancionado en 2018
por Estados Unidos por financiar al ISIS.
Como podéis ver, Trinidad y Tobago parece
haberse convertido en una inesperada
cantera para el yihadismo internacional.
Pero, ¿por qué este país y no otro? Pues
veréis, el idioma de los trinitenses es
el inglés, un activo que le servía
al daesh para aumentar su difusión.
Además, en Trinidad y Tobago no hay
ley que prohíba unirse al “califato”,
y hasta el Brexit, los trinitenses
podían entrar libremente a Reino Unido,
y de ahí al resto de Europa. Vamos, una puerta de
entrada perfecta a Europa para la yihad global.
Con todo, no es de extrañar que Estados Unidos
se haya empezado a interesar en esta pequeña
nación caribeña. de hecho, en 2017 Trump ya se
reunió con el entonces primer ministro del país,
Keith Rowley. En la reunión se
comprometieron a luchar de manera
reforzada contra el terrorismo en las islas
y crearon un nuevo sistema de vigilancia.
No obstante, los analistas siguen bajo alerta: el
caso de Trinidad y Tobago puede ser solo la punta
del iceberg. Muchos vaticinan un aumento
del yihadismo en toda América del Sur.
Pero, ¿cómo de cierto es
esto? Pues bien, veámoslo.
¿UN NUEVO PROBLEMA EN LATINOAMÉRICA?)
Los que nos veáis o procedáis de América
del Sur seguramente cada vez o que os hablan de
terrorismo en la región penséis en guerrillas
como las FARC en Colombia o el Sendero
Luminoso en Perú. Y no es de extrañar,
al fin y al cabo, el terrorismo yihadista en
la región casi siempre ha sido algo anecdótico.
De hecho, nos tenemos que remontar hasta
los años 90 para encontrar los dos grandes
atentados yihadistas en América Latina: el
de la embajada de Israel en Buenos Aires
en 1992 y el de la Asociación Mutual
Israelita Argentina, la AMIA, de 1994.
Y, ¿sabéis quién fue el responsable de
estos ataques? Un viejo conocido: Hezbolá.
En 2006, el fallecido fiscal Alberto Nisman y su
adjunto, Marcelo Martínez Burgos, presentaron el
informe de su investigación sobre el atentado
a la AMIA de 1994. El se acusó directamente al
Estado de Irán de ser principal artífice del
atentado, y a Hezbolá de haberlo ejecutado.
Sin embargo, esta no sería la única ocasión en la
que Irán y su brazo terrorista libanés, Hezbolá,
actuaran en América Latina. Los vínculos
con Venezuela también han sido destacados
en repetidas ocasiones. A través de una retórica
anti-americana, Irán ha conseguido el favor de
Venezuela para poder explotar más fácilmente las
comunidades musulmanas de la región. De hecho,
el Cártel de los Soles, liderado por el
diputado venezolano Diosdado Cabello,
y el Cártel Libanés, creado por Walik Makled
y que tiene estrechos vínculos con Hezbolá,
han colaborado en repetidas ocasiones enviando
armas y narcóticos a Damasco y Teherán a través
de vuelos de la aerolínea venezolana Conviasa.
Una práctica que se conoce como aeroterrorismo.
Sin embargo, y a pesar del infame papel que
la dictadura venezolana juega en la entrada
de Hezbolá en territorio latinoamericano, la
realidad es que este no es el principal punto de
entrada para el terrorismo yihadista a la región.
Para eso tenemos que movernos más al sur,
a una zona extremadamente caliente para
el crimen organizado: la Triple Frontera.
La Triple Frontera es el punto en
que las fronteras de Argentina,
Brasil y Paraguay confluyen, un punto en el que
la corrupción de los funcionarios de aduanas,
los escasos controles fronterizos y el
lavado de activos está a la orden del día.
Aquí, organizaciones del crimen organizado
tanto latinoamericanas como de otras partes
del mundo se dedican al narcotráfico, la trata de
personas o el contrabando, entre otros delitos. Y,
¿quién creéis que también opera aquí?
Efectivamente, Hezbolá, y no precisamente
desde hace poco. Lo ha hecho desde los años 80.
Por eso, los tres países fronterizos y Estados
Unidos han llevado a cabo varias iniciativas
de seguridad en este punto concreto,
tanto para acabar con la presencia del crimen
organizado como del terrorismo yihadista.
Sin embargo, por ahora estas estrategias no han
servido para mucho, y la realidad es que el crimen
se ha intensificado en esta zona. Y, ¿sabéis
qué país está siendo el más perjudicado? Pues,
nada más y nada menos que el país más
grande y poblado de Latinoamérica: Brasil.
Brasil lleva reportando la presencia de
terroristas yihadistas en su territorio
desde hace más de una década. En 2013,
de hecho, la Policía Federal del país
confirmó la presencia de 7 grupos yihadistas
en territorio nacional, entre ellas Hezbolá,
Hamás y Al Qaeda. De hecho, en 2016, Brasil estuvo
a punto de ser víctima de un atentado yihadista.
N4 (Policía de Brasil arresta a 10 personas
sospechosas de “planear ataques terroristas”
para las Olimpiadas de Río de Janeiro. BBC)
Y en 2023 las autoridades brasileñas han avisado
del comienzo de una campaña dentro del país por
parte del Tablighi Jamaat, un movimiento islámico
centenario fundado en la India que ha estado en el
punto de mira de la inteligencia mundial. Es más,
se les ha vinculado, de hecho, con Al Qaeda
y con los atentados de Madrid de 2004.
Ya lo veis, por el momento no ha habido nuevos
atentados yihadistas en Sudamérica desde los que
ocurrieron en los 90 en Argentina, pero
la tensión por la presencia yihadista en
la región va en aumento. Trinidad y
Tobago es el mejor ejemplo de ello.
Ahora muchos analistas piensan que
América Latina podría convertirse
en un nuevo epicentro para el reclutamiento
de yihadistas, pero ¿qué opináis vosotros?
¿Creéis que comenzaremos a ver atentados
yihadistas en Latinoamérica? ¿Tomará
Estados Unidos alguna medida para
evitar que el resto del subcontinente
siga el mismo camino que Trinidad y Tobago?
Podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios. Y como siempre,
si os ha gustado este vídeo,
no olvidéis darle like y suscribiros
a nuestro canal. Y por supuesto,
dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de las novedades que estén por llegar.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar
ahí. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.